je me présente Fabien galinella docteur
en droit et qualifié aux fonctions de
maître de conférence j'ai obtenu le
grade de docteur en droit en 2021 suite
à 5 années de recherches menées au sein
du série sous la direction du Professeur
Eric Gasparin alors comment crée-t-on
une constitution telle est finalement la
question somme toute élémentaire à
laquelle mes travaux essayent de
répondre comment dans une période
troublée celle de la Révolution
française et à partir de presque rien
des députés novices les Girondins sont
parvenus à créer le tout premier modèle
constitutionnel républicain de notre
histoire à l'été 1792 lorsque chut Louis
XVI est la monarchie constitutionnelle
une convention nationale est élu avec
pour mission de donner à la France une
constitution
le contexte est alors tragique pour ne
pas dire chaotique la France est en
guerre avec l'Europe a étant crise
financière et économique le gouvernement
comme je l'ai dit s'était écroulé et la
France devient par la force des choses
une république un régime nouveau qui se
veut inédit en rupture avec la monarchie
un régime nouveau qui a besoin d'une
constitution constitution que doit donc
lui donner la Convention nationale
parmi les membres de cette convention
les Girondins groupés autour de brissau
Condorcet et d'autres figures ils vont
être les premiers ces Girondins à
proposer un projet de Constitution
républicaine ce projet de février 1793
portée par la mouvance girondine
j'essaie de le démontrer est un projet
original et surtout il matérialise la
pensée républicaine gérondine qui répond
à des critères stricts soumission de
tout l'ordre juridique au droit de
l'homme recherche d'une égalité
juridique appliquée au plus grand nombre
important centrale de l'éducation pour
une démocratie fonctionnelle et volonté
d'étendre de la République au-delà des
frontières nationales initialement
englomane et americanophile les
Girondins en viennent finalement à
rédiger une constitution en rupture avec
les leçons des modèles institutionnels
anglo-américains
les plus radicales en circulation dans
ce monde anglo-saxon initialement
partisan d'un monocanéralisme strict les
Girondins qui jugaient le bicaméralisme
anglo-américain trop attente à toi au
pouvoir du peuple et bien ces Girondins
viendront finalement à la fin de leur
expérience politique admettre que le
mono-caméralisme strict était voué à
l'échec initialement pacifiste ces
Girondins en viennent aussi à déclarer
la guerre à l'Europe à vouloir revenir
sur la veste valienne souveraineté des
États au profit d'une nouvelle
souveraineté celle des peuples que doit
émanciper la République il mèneront pour
cela une croisade pour la liberté
universelle telle est le mot de brisso
une croisade dont le but sera de
réformer totalement l'ordre
international au profit de la liberté
des peuples au profit de la République
et d'une grande alliance des nations
libres menée par l'Angleterre les
États-Unis et bien entendu par la France
cette croisade pour la liberté
universelle cette guerre menée au
monarchie coalisée aux empires coloniaux
aboutira à la chute des Girondins en mai
1793 leur échec leur chute puis leur
exécution entraînera également leur
projet constitutionnel dans l'oubli un
projet constitutionnel qui aujourd'hui
je l'espère doit désormais être
considéré à sa juste valeur comme le
premier projet républicain pour notre
pays